[music]
>> Hi, I'm Amol, CEO of Nori Atentic.
>> [music]
>> We deploy an AI employee that
understands your company, your code,
docs, Slack, [music] and other kinds of
data.
We spend a lot of time thinking about
how coding agents really work.
Most people think coding agents only
write code. But if you ask me, that's
just bad marketing.
>> [music]
>> Forget the name for a second. Coding
agents can do almost anything.
>> [music]
>> There's just one trick. You have to be
able to think like an agent to get it to
do what you want it to do.
>> [music]
>> Today, we're going to talk about how we
use coding agents to do something most
people think agents are terrible at,
make visual artifacts, like slides,
docs, [music] and yeah, even video.
>> [music]
>> Every day, the world pours something
like 34,000 human years into making
slide decks.
Most of that time isn't the thinking,
it's the fiddling. [music]
A deck that takes 10 hours should really
take about 25 minutes once you remove
all the formatting and the branding and
the moving things around.
Say you need to make a slide. What do
you do?
You open a tool, PowerPoint, Slides,
Figma, Canva,
and then you start manipulating a
canvas.
Every one of these tools is built for
human hands and human eyes. Click, drag,
drop, resize, snap to grid, all motions
and patterns that make sense for our
geospatial view of the world. There is a
data structure underneath, but it's in a
format that only the application can
read.
What happens when you hand these tools
to an agent? Well, the output comes out
all wrong.
Things overlap in weird ways, you can't
see the text, there's no alignment, It's
just garbage.
AI skeptics say that it's not just the
tools. Agents fundamentally can't reason
about space. And there are whole
benchmarks like Arc AGI that are built
exactly around that premise.
There's a famous little test for this
from developer Simon Willison.
He asks every new model the same thing.
Can you draw a pelican riding a bicycle?
But there's a trick. The agent is only
allowed to use SVG.
It's a quick gut check for whether a
model can reason about space at all.
Here's some examples of what the models
actually give you on this test. And
[music] yeah,
these are pretty bad. Like genuinely
deeply really bad.
>> [music]
>> So, does that mean it's hopeless? Agents
are just doomed to be bad at graphics?
No, I don't think so.
If you ask me, it's not the model, it's
the medium.
If I asked you, someone who is
presumably human, to handwrite an SVG of
a pelican, you wouldn't be able to do
that either.
>> [music]
>> SVGs are just a wall of numbers. You
can't go from a wall of numbers to a
pelican, you just can't see that way.
That's just not how people think.
We think graphically. So, we build tools
that let us draw on a canvas.
Figma MCPs, PowerPoint CLIs, screenshot
and replace loops, what do all of these
agent tools have in common?
They all approach the problem like a
human.
But an AI is not a human. Asking an AI
to use a canvas is like asking a human
to write SVG by hand. It doesn't really
make sense. You need to give the AI
tools based on how it thinks, not in
pixels, in language. Words, tokens,
structure, that is its native medium.
Imagine a language that's incredible at
describing layout. That models have seen
and trained on billions of examples of.
That they understand intuitively.
that renders to pixels and can run
everywhere.
Oh, right.
HTML lets the model think in structure.
HTML tags have meanings built into the
language. A heading, a chart, a grid,
and the browser turns it all into
pixels. So, the model never actually
places a coordinate, and you can get all
sorts of visual effects, charts and
layouts, fonts and motion, all of it for
free.
Remember that pelican from earlier? Now,
ask it to do the same exact task, but in
HTML.
Same bird, but now it's in a structure
that the model can reason about. And you
can read and theme and edit every single
line of it.
I spent my whole life building slide
decks with PowerPoint. So, I always
thought that those two things, slide
decks and PowerPoint, were synonyms.
[music]
But that's just not really true, is it?
PowerPoint is a tool that you use to
make slide decks. The deck itself,
that's just the presentation mode.
And as it turns out, no one in your
audience is going to care how you got to
the presentation mode. The editing
format is totally arbitrary.
>> [music]
>> So, you can just pick the editing format
that the agents are already good at,
HTML, and if you need to render to a
different format like PDF later on.
We use this HTML trick to build all of
our slide decks, our board decks, and
our sales decks.
>> [music]
>> These are real things that we actually
present and send out constantly.
We use it for our docs, too. It gives
our docs color and vibrancy, all while
following our brand.
And of course, we also use it to make
videos like this one.
What you're watching is just HTML and
CSS. It's literally just divs all the
way down.
Almost everything is better with a
little structure and a little bit of
color. Plain text is a choice, generally
a choice of convenience, but it's
usually the wrong one if you're actually
trying to create something of use.
Now, I do want to take a quick beat here
and point out that a beautiful deck on
its own is generally not worth anything.
You still have to go and get all of that
content, all of the things that actually
populate that deck, right?
Well, again, we can think like the
model. If you just give the model access
to your data, say your call transcripts
or your emails, you can have the model
build the deck end to end. Let your
agents do all the grunt work while you
focus on vision and story.
That's what Nori Sessions lets you do.
I've built entire board decks for my
phone on the subway during my commute.
Why? Because our Nori bot lives in the
fabric of our company.
Of course, Nori ships with everything
you need to make this all work, so don't
bother reinventing the wheel.
That's my little spiel. Thanks for
listening.
If you have just one takeaway, it's
this.
Stop thinking like a user. Think like
the model.
Give it the right language, and for
graphics, all you need is HTML.
>> [music]